hey I've got a great documentary
recommendation for you today it's called
rolling papers and this follows the
denver post as well as one of the first
or maybe the first major marijuana
editor ricardo baca and what happened
when Colorado legalized recreational
marijuana is the Denver Post the
newspaper there that some newspapers
actually do still exist uh decided we're
going to have a cannabis editor who is
going to be all over everything from
what is going on legally with marijuana
what is going on in terms of the pot
world and dispensaries in Colorado what
about uh you even getting down to
reviewing certain strains of marijuana
etcetera etcetera and the documentary
rolling papers covers ricardo baca and
the Denver Post building up this
infrastructure of we're taking marijuana
seriously the way we would take
restaurant a critique the same we way we
would take the legality around the
internet whatever uh in the course of
this documentary and it's really really
good and I encourage you to watch it we
learn a lot about the complexities that
exist when you have a substance in
marijuana that is illegal still at the
federal level decriminalized in some
states legal medicinally in some states
and now in a couple of states legal
recreationally and it is an absolute in
total mass it's an absolute in total
mess in terms of as one example child
services right child services in
Colorado which I'll services exist in
many many states uh how should they
consider marijuana use in evaluating
whether a child is safe with their
parents uh when it comes to alcohol some
amount of alcohol consumption is okay
for parents to be participating in if
there's no evidence that they are
endangering their children or whatever
once you legalize recreational marijuana
you can no longer really say well any
use of this legal substance makes you an
unfit parent that's one type of issue
that Ricardo Baca and the Denver Post
cover in the the of sort of laying out
of this documentary have either you guys
seen the stock
I have not have you Rachel I have it I
recommend that you bookmark it on
netflix or find it on amazon it is
really really good we're talking about
the documentary rolling papers and of
course you can check out all of my
recommendations if you go to david
pakman.com slash recommendations